it looked like something out of the cold
war and rarely since then as a delivery
meant so much potentially for east-west
relations america's ambassador in moscow
carrying his government's written
response to russia's demands over
security in europe and ukraine
while in washington america's chief
diplomat spelled out what was in the
letter
our actions over the past week
have sharpened the choice facing russia
now
we've laid out a diplomatic path
we've lined up steep consequences should
russia choose further aggression
now we'll continue to press forward and
prepare
it remains up to russia to decide how to
respond
we're ready either way
the letter follows more diplomacy today
french german russian and ukrainian
negotiators meeting in paris
in the ukrainian capital life trundles
on somewhere between humdrum normality
and looming conflict
ukraine
the message from ukraine's president to
his people this week don't panic
invasion's not imminent but in a cold
and drafty kiev market they didn't seem
[Music]
he told me he stopped listening to the
politicians that one is here on the
mission
preparing with his reserve unit instead
for the moment russia invades we even
decided to make the rehearsal
uh
of of what smaller streets we use to get
out of the city even though your
government says an invasion is not
imminent uh
as i mentioned i do not follow the
guidance of the government i do follow
the guidance of
my military commanders
while ukrainians have been told to keep
calm and carry on events away from here
are hardly reassuring russia is
threatening swift retaliatory action if
its demands are not met by the west
if invasion isn't imminent there's a lot
of russian heavy armour on the move
waiting for them if they cross over into
ukraine british supplied anti-tank
missiles ukrainians have released
pictures of british soldiers instructing
their use
but will that be enough to stop a
russian invasion
not if you listen to this former prime
minister of ukraine what we need out of
the west
we need the shipment of legal defensive
weapon
this would bolster ukrainian defense
system anti-aircraft systems
anti-missile systems electronic warfare
that's what is needed
there is a disconnect between western
efforts to meet russian demands
and the military buildup a constant
stream of pictures of russia's war
machine
unless diplomacy can prevail the region
still seems on course for conflict
dominic waghorn sky news kiev